hi my name is michael and i'm
palestinian hi my name is cheryl and i'm
mexican
and today we're going to be swapping
meals what did you pick for me because
it's a lot of meat for one girl today
you're going to be eating something
called
which is a meat pie usually sweetheart
comes in smaller pies but
this place obviously loves large
portions and then you're going to be
eating shawrma
the dish i chose for you it is called
the klayuda it has cabbage
beans quesillo which is what we're known
for like a huge long string cheese
it's the best part honestly of the
collage and i also ordered you
a taco al pastor so i'm really excited
for you to try it alright
let's get into it this is a shawarma how
do you say it
shawarma shawarma yes thank you
authentic this is so big how do i even
start eating it
i mean honestly you have options you can
like fold it up and bite it you can use
a four
like whatever you're most comfortable
with i like to build it up and bite it
are they typically like this big it's
not usually that much meat that seems
like a pretty large portion
[Music]
it's really like flavorful so i know
like they
marinated this but it's really good it's
like sweet when my family and i go back
to the middle east
my mom's always like gotta get some
shawarma spices and you know we get the
vacuum sealed and we take them home
and she'll throw it in the freezer and
she'll use it to make her own chowing at
home
i went into the store and i'm like these
spices look so good like how
how can i not have these spices in my
life and also shawarma
typically is cooked on like a vertical
rotisserie
so there's a large history of arab
immigration to
latin america specifically so you'll see
a lot of arab influence in
a lot of latino dishes mexicans got
inspired by that and actually
took like cooking their meat on the spit
and that's how we have al pastor tacos
now
me and my uh latinx friends have always
kind of bonded over
the similarities in our food and our
culture and just like our love for music
and like our love for parties we love
the parties
and i'm eating this um taco al pastor
and i'm like this is so good especially
with this salsa oh my god it's so good
the tacos al pastor actually do resemble
shawarma to me they kind of have a
similar taste and a similar texture
all right let me finish this taco and
then i want to try this clay with this
so bad
i would say i'm gonna finish this but
i'm not too much
i just love tacos that was a lot of meat
i need to drink my
rose drink i've never had rose drink i
feel like
just the name is pretty i just
envisioned myself like
in my bathtub with rose petals i don't
think this is the same
like me drinking my bath water oh my
gosh
it's so sweet i'm just gonna finish it
okay i'm done in our countries and our
regions
that we're from people really know how
to like
use the land and like use the resources
available
as like a lot of other cultures do but
it's not in my experience as common of a
thing in like in america
to like drink rose water for example
people know rose water exists and like
people use the toner i use the toner i
need to drink my
horchata yes so it has cinnamon
it has milk it's sweet it's
refreshing so it's like a good it's a
fresca so
the name means like fresh water so it's
supposed to like
refresh you and it's so good for the
summer hot time
i love things that taste kind of like
cereal so me making that connection
like really like just elevates it for me
i need to take a break because i'm about
to finish this we
we need to get to the glyuda because
that is gonna be a beast to even get
through
it's like a huge pizza and i don't know
if they cut it into like slices
you know what i think they technically
did but i'm gonna grab a knife
i love tortillas i think a crunchy
tortilla is like a godsend
i love the beef and the chorizo flavor
the quesadilla is good
avocado i have like a strange
relationship with avocado
it's complicated you all got to get your
collagula because this is good
especially with the salsa
i'm going to try the spiha which is also
known as a meat pie
and i already love it because i love
thin crust
so much flavor i love that it's not
super greasy either
and then we have onion and tomato and
meat
i love meat so anything with like a
bread and meat perfect i always eat the
same thing because i'm afraid of new
things
but i think when you take a risk and
like learn about different cultures
now i have so many other food choices to
choose from
my heart i absolutely would eat a flavor
again
and now i know a spot where to get
kaleida and i'll honestly probably tell
my friends to get some too
y'all can share yes i'm gonna need to
share with them this is
this is huge
[Music]
you